comme je vous le disais de nombreuses
innovations concernant les
infrastructures routières sont
développées ici au sein du corps de
colas et c'est le cas notamment de watou
et la route solaire ce sont des panneaux
photovoltaïques incrusté dans le
revêtement routier pour en parler nous
sommes avec davy michon bonjour bonjour
foyer bienvenu.merci nous accueillir
vous êtes responsable commercial de
watou et groupe colas
[Musique]
ou à tout et c'est quoi finalement what
ouais c'est quoi c'est une revêtement
photovoltaïque circulable donc la
prouesse technologique hommes du groupe
colas ça a été finalement de pouvoir
encapsulé une cellule photovoltaïque
dans des résines de protection que l'on
vient recouvrir ensuite ici on le voit
de granulats de verre pour que cette
ville soit adhérentes et c'est
infiniment un revêtement qui permet de
valoriser l'espace public disponible là
où il ya finalement du parking
disponibles du trottoir on va pouvoir y
ajouter un revêtement photovoltaïques
pour produire de l'énergie solaire et
utiliser cette énergie solaire pour
alimenter soit des équipements soit
faire de l'auto consommation locale
l'histoire démarre en 2011 où nous
travaillons pendant quatre ans de 2011 à
2015 sur une première phase de r&d qui
va nous permettre de travailler avec le
cea tech et l'institut national énergie
solaire qui est un organisme
mondialement reconnu et à l'issue de
cette r&d donc en 2015 on va sortir la
première dalle photovoltaïque premier
revêtement photovoltaîque circulable
donc what works dont vous avez un
exemplaire ici un échantillon et à
partir de 2015 on va commencer des
expérimentations pendant trois à quatre
ans donc jusqu'en 2018 2019 qui vont
nous permettre donc de pouvoir faire
progresser au niveau technique la
dernière voiture et de débouchés à
partir de 2019 donc sur une première
gamme qui va proposer quatre solutions
watts way et notamment donc de deux
solutions aujourd'hui qui sont
maintenant commercialisé donc une
première solution qui s'appelle loi tout
est pas qu elle nous paraît donc de
rendre autonome des petits équipements
tout autour de la voirie et puis une
seconde solution qu'on appelle de l'auto
consommation locale permettant
d'apporter de l'énergie à des clients
privés et publics ou est-ce qu'on peut
retrouver ces deux produits du coup dans
le monde je suppose parce que ça se fait
aussi à l'international alors en france
et international absolument au
développement de ses deux deux solutions
donc aujourd'hui ou à tous et pâques est
une solution qui permet de rendre
autonome des équipements liés à la
mobilité douce par exemple on va pouvoir
alimenter des bornes de recharge vélo ou
de trottinettes et là on a des très bons
exemples aujourd'hui donc par exemple à
vauréal on attend en région parisienne
mais on a également à moosch dans le
dans le 49 voilà donc des abris vélos
connectés sécurisé alimenté avec de la
borne de recharge vélo via la dengue
watts way et puis on peut également
sécurisé des passages piétons avec des
petits peuples est lumineux qui vont
nous permettre de d'illuminer un passage
piéton actuellement on a des exemples à
bonneuil sur marne en région parisienne
également ou sur le conseil
départemental du 44 donc ça voyez c'est
très concret c sont dès aujourd'hui une
gamme qui est commercialisé avec des
clients qui ont fait le choix de boîte
web et puis sur l'auto consommation
locale on a également des solutions qui
sont développés alors en angleterre par
exemple la forme turn on a un centre de
tri aujourd'hui qui est alimentée avec
des al watwan mais également au japon où
on a un client japonais qui souhaite
pousser encore son mix énergétique qui
fait déjà du photovoltaïque
traditionnels et qui aujourd'hui rajoute
encore une solution photovoltaïque
nouvelle avec whatwg est sûre c'est
parti l'avenir pour moi tout et c'est
quoi alors on nous sommes très
enthousiastes et très confiant sur
l'avenir
puisque toutes ces périodes itération
que nous avons quitté à partir de 2019
pour rentrer finalement dans une phase
de commercialisation nous ont permis de
progresser techniquement
et de pouvoir avoir une dalle qui n'ont
plus résistantes qui produit 21 % de
plus qu elle ne produisait en 2018 et à
partir de 2019 changement de modèle on
va re modéliser la dalle qui va devenir
plus résistants qui va produire 21 % en
plus et puis aujourd'hui naissance d'une
dalle troisième génération plus grande
qui est le produit 156 watt crête est
donc cette période là maintenant on va
nous permettre de pouvoir travailler sur
la baisse des coûts et puis notre avenir
maintenant c'est de pouvoir répondre aux
enjeux environnementaux qui se
présentent devant nous on le voit avec
aujourd'hui donc des phénomènes
climatiques très important et donc
l'obligation d'avoir une neutralité
carbone très rapidement et puis de
pouvoir répondre aussi à l'enjeu de la
hausse des coûts de l'énergie et la
ouate way est finalement koch deux cases
fondamental pour notre avenir commun de
pouvoir finalement produire de l'énergie
sur de l'espace disponible sans faire de
mitage supplémentaires sont de
grignotage de l'espace
supplémentaires et donc je trouve que là
où on a déjà dû photovoltaïques
traditionnels sur la toiture et que l'on
a de l'espace disponible tel que des
parkings et là je pense à des logiques
si logisticiens des grands déçus grandes
surfaces commerciales par exemple mais
pas que eh bien on va pouvoir utiliser
cet espace disponible pour pouvoir
également installé une solution
photovoltaïque et produire de l'énergie
donc vous voyez on a un certain
enthousiasme et grande confiance sur
l'avenir de la technologie watts web
pour les années qui viennent merci david
michaud merci à vous responsable
commercial white ou et groupe colas et
nous on va prendre la direction
maintenant du laboratoire du corps et
biens pour découvrir de nouvelles
innovations concernant les
infrastructures routières